you guys asked for it M1 Ultra versus M2
Ultra has there really been that big of
an upgrade well in some of these real
world tests there were barely any
difference but in other ones it was
massive let's get started with the
differences with the actual Hardware
itself you can't really tell externally
but one update is that HDMI port
allowing up to 8K resolution or 4K 240
and the overall display support is much
more powerful the other Hardware
difference is Wi-Fi 6E and I did a full
video on this showing that even if you
don't have Wi-Fi 6E even with Wi-Fi 5
the speed is way faster and with better
range compared to Wi-Fi 6 in the old
model so that is a nice upgrade now I'm
going to make this more interesting for
you because I'm not only going to
compare it price versus price but I'm
also throwing in the 5 800 M1 Ultra that
I upgraded to 128 gigs of RAM and to the
full unbanned M1 Ultra chip so we have
48 core M1 Ultra compared to 60 core and
the 64 core M1 Ultra which normally more
cores equals more power right well we'll
take a look at that and we'll also talk
about thermals and fan noise right off
the bat looking at geekbench 6's single
core score the performance hasn't really
gone up very much and the difference we
do have is because the M2 Ultra the
clock speeds are slightly higher in
terms of multi-core score we are now
above 20 000 for the much tougher geek
bench six that's the difference of
roughly 17 and a half percent uh and I
honestly was expecting a little bit more
in this test getting into graphics with
3D Marks Wildlife extreme the M2 Ultra
is more than 26 percent faster this year
for the 4 000 model and five percent
faster than our fully upgraded ones so
you're saving money and getting better
performance and if you compare FPS per
core I was impressed here because the M2
Ultra does better than the M1 Ultra that
has the 64 core so we have less cores
and more performance per core now maxing
out the CPU with cinebench R23 here we
only see a 15 and a half percent
difference in terms of CPU performance
less than in geekbench 6. with that I
also saw more power usage to get this
performance which once again shows that
the M2 cores that are in the CPU they're
pretty much overclocked M1 cores and
because of that extra power and heat
what's going to happen to our fan noise
and temperatures well running cinebench
I got 85 degrees Celsius on the M2 Ultra
whereas the M1 Ultra only hit 65 that is
a big swing in temperatures for the CPU
now that is because the fans in all of
the Mac Studios including the M2 ultra
run at idle yes they run at the slowest
speed possible and they don't really
need to kick up we just have a little
bit more Heat and the M2 model is better
in terms of coil wine now I didn't have
any issues with my M1 Ultra but other
people did this one doesn't have any
issues at all and other people are
reporting that they are not having it
either now for programmers using xcode
here I was a bit disappointed to see
that the performance improvements are
pretty much non-existent I mean we have
a few seconds saved but definitely not
worth upgrading to the M2 Ultra and it
might have to do with just the
efficiency of the code it's already so
fast that we can't eke out any more
performance so keep that in mind and in
terms of logic music production and here
I hit 320 tracks only 15 more than the
same price M1 Ultra and actually less
than the one that I had upgraded to 128
gigs of RAM so it seems like here we are
more RAM limited and if you work with
logic it's definitely not worth
upgrading in terms of web browsing
performance and web-based apps
speedometer shows a big improvement with
the M2 Chip we have faster memory
involved as well so you might not notice
it because it is so fast already but the
difference is there and as for blender
holy moly this is where people are going
to want to upgrade for the BMW project
literally double the performance and
then our 5800 R1 pretty much double it
is right there now how could this be
possible when we have only about a 28
Improvement if we calculate the hardware
itself the extra cores and then slightly
Higher free and see well we previously
had issues with scaling of the M1 Ultra
because of buffer issues well Apple has
reworked all of that and now it just
screams in areas where it used to be
bottlenecked as far as the party tug
test once again we are seeing literally
a doubling up performance for the same
price it is absolutely incredible now
for the photo editors out there using
the latest version of Lightroom here we
are going from 4 minutes 15 seconds down
to 3 minutes and 15 seconds roughly a 33
Improvement which is really impressive
and Lightroom does use both the CPU and
the GPU really pushes the system now for
certain Photoshop tasks the same thing
happens for example for HDR here we went
from 30 seconds down to 20 for the same
price point which is very impressive
pretty much just one year later now of
course both of these are very quick but
if you're doing a ton of this or you're
working on huge projects a lot of layers
the performance Improvement is
impressive now as far as video editing I
have a variety of tests here because
that is what we do and to stabilize a
one minute clip we went from seven
seconds down to four this is a huge huge
huge Improvement even though seven
seconds is still fast four you pretty
much click a few seconds later you are
done now exporting a five minute 4K
project with color grading Luts and film
grain well we went from a minute 17 down
to 42 seconds and that is because the M1
Ultra even though it has dual encoders
it wasn't really able to use them and
that's why scaling was terrible and we
personally at Max Tech settled for an M1
Max Max studio well now the difference
is here and for five minutes literally
taking 42 sec is incredible and the
crazy thing is if you use DaVinci
Resolve well here we go from 49 seconds
down to 30. can you imagine even just a
few years ago saying that you can export
5 minutes and 30 seconds or 20 minutes
in two minutes time rendering is no
longer an issue you can't even go get a
drink anymore while you wait pushing the
graphics to their limits intervention
resolve using noise reduction both
spatial and temporal this is a super
tough task to test the raw performance
and previously we had 16 FPS out of 24
and with the 5 800 r model that was 20
frames per second well now we can hit 28
for the two thousand dollar model yes
that is a massive massive improvements
once again showing that we had a major
bottleneck with the M1 Ultra here now my
clip was 24 frames second so it did it
perfectly live in real time which is
incredible
um and now it can actually do more than
that and if you spend the extra thousand
bucks for the unbinned M2 Ultra that
will actually hit 30 not a big
difference by the way if you want to see
a full comparison between the 4000 and
it's paying the extra thousand bucks let
me know down in the comments and enable
those notifications now getting into
tougher footage for example red 8K raw
playback is perfect it is awesome and
then exporting this I was shocked to see
that the difference is pretty much
negligible now yeah the four thousand
dollar option is the same speed as a
5800 and I don't really know why because
our Graphics is almost maxed out we're
using a lot of CPU there must be
something with the codec or how
um we're working with these files that's
limiting this it just does not make
sense now in terms of proraz because we
have this Pros in coaches and decoders
well here the new M2 Ultra did this in
30 seconds compared to 41 and 43. now
the numbers are so quick because these
systems are so dang fast but of course
if it's not a five minute project if
it's a 20 you can multiply that because
we have absolutely no throttling I've
done tests from 20 scaling down to five
scaling up to an hour and the results
are linear because we don't have
throttling so we're seeing those
performance improvements and with extra
graphics performance you just have more
overhead for effects and of course this
has Luts and it's color graded as well
now in terms of Canon 8K raw this is a
super tough codec and it plays back
perfectly with the M2 Ultra with the M1
it was not perfect you would have to
lower your resolution your timeline and
as far as exporting once again it's just
slightly faster just like we had with
the red AK raw so maybe on these crazy
codex we have some other buffer
limitation as well I really don't know
but it is still incredibly fast so with
that said is it worth upgrading from the
M1 Ultra to the M2 Ultra well in a few
cases yes especially for blender 3D
rendering or other 3D rendering
applications absolutely but for other
people like these tests that you guys
saw it might not be worth it at all or
only if you do a crazy amount of work
and saving time will help you the M1
Ultra is still very fast and if you're
looking to buy one right now not upgrade
you could still get a crazy good deal on
a used model from somebody that's trying
to upgrade so definitely go ahead and
check out what you're able to find click
that Circle above and let me know if you
want to see the M1 Ultra bin versus
unbin video check out one of those and I
will see you in the next one